foreign
Jade I want to talk about something that
is kind of boring but is also stressing
people out and it starts with f then it
goes D then it goes I then it goes C oh
okay you like that I think you just gave
it away Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation and this is a word people
really you only saw it at like banks in
the little gold placard remember FDIC
but now it's all over the news yeah
that's what they say because of you know
Silicon Valley Bank uh be the bank run
the collapse and all of a sudden FDIC is
way more important so I want to squelch
some of the fears out there that people
have around is my money safe in the bank
that's what this comes down to yes so
let's talk about what the FDIC is and
how it works they ensure trillions of
dollars uh Bank deposits at more than
five thousand banks in Savings in the
U.S it's an independent Federal agency
that kind of functions like insurance
for the banks so the banks are saying we
need help taking on this risk in case
something were to happen and we can't
fund it you guys step in and fund the
it's that simple we have car insurance
because we can't cover the big stuff and
the banks do the same for themselves so
they pay these insurance premiums and um
that's how it works so how does the
coverage work then George so if a bank
fails the FDIC swoops in and reimburses
customers for any lost money so if you
had 40 Grand with a bank the bank
collapses the government's like hey we
got your back I'm not losing anything
thing you're not losing a dime so they
take over the failed bank and they work
to transfer the loans and deposit that
to a healthy Bank to where your money is
safe and they also now have ownership of
all the bank's assets wow okay so they
can sell off what they need they can
liquidate whatever they need to in order
to make sure your money's secure exactly
so how much money does the FDIC insure
it's up to 250 000 per depositor per
insured bank for each account ownership
category so that's a lot of word salad
to say this if you're a single person
you're covered up to 250 000 that's
that's a bag if you have a joint account
you and Sam have a joint account you're
covered up to five hundred thousand
dollars wow because it's 250 per person
okay so now can you explain a little bit
on if let's say I'm at let's say I'm at
Chase Bank and I've got a savings
account that's got a large sum of money
and let's say I've got a checking
account that's got some money and let's
just say I have a I don't know a couple
of CDs or something with them yes so
this is where the account categories
come into play and so checking and
savings would be one category okay
versus a CD or a trust those would be
different categories okay and so if you
have I don't know why this this probably
relates to no one out there who's like
well that's perfect I have eight hundred
thousand dollars sitting across my only
you could open Accounts at different
banks yeah if you want to be safe so 250
and One Bank 250 another bank 215
another bank so case in point let's just
say sold your house and you've got a
nice little Nest Egg of change let's say
you sold your house you got 300 000
you're sitting on and you're like um
that's just over the limit you could if
you really wanted to be safe you could
say I'm going to put some of this with
Ally Bank high yield savings account and
I'm going to put some of it you know at
one of the other high yield savings
accounts yeah and I would rather have it
in a high-yield savings account anyways
facts making you know three or four
percent so it doesn't apply to a lot of
people but everyone's kind of freaked
out by this but rest assured the FDIC
has never failed in this way they've
never run out of money they've got you
know over a hundred billion dollars plus
any Bank assets that come their way
right through these collapses that they
can sell off now what this doesn't cover
Jade is Investments so you're starting
right right right your mutual funds your
crypto life insurance annuities and so
you're taking on a risk by investing
into the stock market the bank's not
going to cover you that's true the only
way that there might be some coverage
there is you know when you first put
that money over to The Brokerage before
you've invested it and it's just kind of
like sitting money on hand in that money
market that would be protected I would
think up to 250 000. but go ahead go on
ahead and invest that money don't just
let that money be that's the bigger
thing if you called in and you're
worried about this one what are you
doing sitting on 800 000 tripping either
invest it put it towards real estate
yeah use it towards something
um maybe you just have that across
multiple high-yield savings accounts
worst case that's what I would do if I
had that much sitting in cash yeah which
I don't so don't come at me we won't
come at you so here's the bottom line
stop worrying about everyone else but
yourself you are in control of your
finances sleep easy at night this is not
a problem people need to worry about no
they're scared of like what if everyone
did a bank run at once in the United
States and we didn't have enough we got
bigger problems at that point America
yeah and we've never exp I mean we
experienced it with toilet paper
remember that during the pandemic
everyone freaked out there wasn't going
to be enough toilet paper and all of a
sudden there wasn't enough toilet paper
yes but I never met and I might be going
too far here I never met one person who
was like Jade I wasn't able to take care
of business we found a way listen you
guys did you meet anybody I'm just
saying I'm not trying to use generic
brand okay you go down to one ply you're
in a dark situation I had somebody give
me a bunch of one play roles like as a
Fail-Safe in case we ran out and do you
know what happened 2020 went and went on
in that one play stayed in our garage I
ended up giving it away because I'm not
there's some places I'm not going hey
that brings a whole new meaning to if
crap hits the fan there you go I'll end
it there but hey we've got a great blog
on this topic FDIC not toilet paper go
to ramseysolutions.com we'll also put it
in the show notes